and so I just took my unboxing knife to
this bad boy and now I'm ripping off the
plastic and that's going to lift off the
top lid is going to look this iphone 5s
out of the box is going to take a look
at the contents of the box yes bleh Mika
is a huge fan of unboxing the games
reviewer loves watching other people
unpack electronics whether smartphones
or computer games this Berliner is
mesmerised by unpacking as many bound
books when I'm watching unboxing videos
then I unpack along with them in my head
and imagine being that person ripping
open the packet pulling out the gadget
and inhaling that new product smell but
I not that's the feeling you get when
you watch a good unboxing video in also
missing people no code Russia is a
director in his spare time the Berlin
drinks distributor makes unboxing videos
for fun then he uploads them to his own
YouTube channel does noah autocad phone
just more wire as auto camp is also a
min ago started I was endless no code
Russia would love to make money with his
unboxing videos the 36 year old thinks
the Java serves a purpose first
individual I like to give people a feel
for whether the product offers value for
money and to show what the product can
do I help customers make purchasing
decisions and show why you should buy
the product I am here to emboss with you
the new nokia e61 American Vincent no
yen in the very first unboxing video
made in 2006 she can see it's very thin
no yan came up with the term unboxing
at first there was little interest in
his idea but then the unboxing craze
took off online these days people are
making more and more unboxing videos and
the most popular ones are getting
millions of clicks that's got scientists
talking sociologist Andre Nowakowski
from Berlin's free university has
started studying unboxing with a
research team thankless also we think
there's a type of hedonism involved
there's a vicarious thrill this is a
product I can't have right now and can't
unpack so that's why I watch other
people unpacking it none Shaw unpacking
also prompts happy childhood memories
for many users they remember unwrapping
Christmas presents as a child or
receiving birthday presents some say
unboxing is all about nostalgia for days
long past for me ho its entire album on
open these days i still love unpacking
something new but i don't get lego
castles for Christmas anymore watching
unboxing videos helps you keep that
feeling alive these are these avoidance
bavar and now companies have even
started producing their own professional
unboxing for advertising purposes this
is one internet craze that suits them to
a tee after all unboxers love shiny
packages and expensive products no code
alicia says that's legitimate so much
but I so for instance this is a cheap
gadget the packaging is really thin it's
cheap and this is an expensive Apple
peripheral from just mobile or you can
tell that you're buying a good product
from the packaging in the outside that's
my entire display booked and I think you
really drawn to it my food is your uncle
but not everyone's a fan of unboxing the
craze has spawned parody videos online
oh my god oh my god Mitchell PlayStation
4
others go even further some cyber
activists want this trend to end they
think unboxing videos are shallow
there you go critics say unboxers have
it all wrong they should focus on
function not form shift says much ado
about nothing